cost optimization is about more than
saving money
it's about maximizing the return on what
you're spending
let's walk through how to optimize your
costs for google kubernetes engine or
gke
today we'll be talking about some
general tips for getting started with
cost optimization
and some best practices in other words
let's go beyond your gke bill
[Music]
individuals and companies alike are
talking about experimenting with
and deploying apps on kubernetes and of
course gke is made to scale as you add
more traffic
and more applications however scaling
your apps
might also mean scaling your costs and
as more teams in your organization
use kubernetes it may become more
complex to manage
let's look at some ways to think about
how you can optimize your usage
and your costs for gke i'll get started
by quickly going over some basics
and then talk about the business and
culture side then
i'll go over some general technical tips
simply put
what you're paying for with gke itself
is primarily two things
the managed architecture for actually
running the kubernetes cluster
and the resources that your apps are
running on such as cpus memory and
storage
there's also a few other things that
will affect your costs like networking
and resource location
we'll dive into details to better
understand and optimize different areas
in these videos but no matter what the
costs are
it's hard to make decisions without
knowing where they're coming from
being able to have visibility into all
the different moving pieces is
incredibly important
and a great place to start might be
using a dashboard to help visualize your
resources
the next videos will go over some tips
for exactly how to do that
but try to always remember that the more
you understand about the full details of
your applications
the more opportunities you'll have to
optimize and don't worry
you'll hear me say that plenty of times
on top of that
you shouldn't forget about the people
that are actually writing the
applications
when you're in a rush to deploy an
application sometimes shortcuts get
taken
or maybe your organization has grown so
large that they completely abstract
kubernetes away from the teams
and then they're not even sure how their
apps make it to gke
either way keeping developers operators
and everyone else in the dark
about how their applications actually
run might cause more harm than good
instead consider spending the time to
train your technical teams on kubernetes
best practices
like online classes code labs even
videos like this one
when teams understand and care about the
costs it takes to run their apps
the more those teams will be able to
optimize beyond that you can also
implement guard rails to protect
yourself from
updates that might significantly affect
your costs
there are ways to automatically enforce
policies and set up quotas for resources
that we'll also cover in this video
series
building a culture of awareness and
accountability is critical to being able
to optimize your costs
keeping all of that in mind let's switch
over to some best practices on the
technical side
you can find reference links in the
description if you want to read more
about any of these
so if you're already using gke you're
probably aware of your production
clusters
but how many development clusters do you
have smaller teams might work well with
one cluster per developer
but you should actually look at
multi-tenant clusters to save on
overhead
by using namespaces and policies to keep
resources capped and isolated
dev teams can have the room to
experiment that won't lead to any
surprise bills
on top of that there's a few add-ons
that come with gke clusters
that are important for production
environments but might not be needed for
your development environments
for each of your smaller clusters
consider disabling or limiting add-ons
if you're not using them
such as cloud logging and monitoring
horizontal pod auto scaling
the kubernetes dashboard and coop dns
most can be disabled with a one-line
command
these small add-ons can add up so the
better you understand what your apps
need
and the environment around them the more
you can optimize
speaking of what your apps need do you
know what your pod disruption budgets
are
you can set the number of pods or the
percentage of pods
that can be taken down when doing
voluntary disruptions like
upgrades or auto scaling think about the
minimum amount of pots that you need
to run without disrupting your
application's users and
think about that for each application
independently
pod disruption budgets can help keep
your apps running as you configure audio
scaling without over provisioning
we'll talk more about auto scaling soon
if you're not sure about how to figure
out things like resource utilization or
pod disruption budgets stay tuned
on the next video we'll talk all about
monitoring your gke environment
and getting better observability
remember to check out the link in the
description for the full guide on gke
cost optimization
you